hey guys it is finally Friday and here's
five fascinating stories from the world
of gaming to get you all caught up first
up today it seems people staring at
their phones constantly to catch pokemon
is causing some trouble thousands of
complaints have been filed with the
federal trade commission over Pokemon go
including one such complaint from a
person claiming they almost hit a child
in part because of the game polygon on
colored 72 complaints that have been
filed so far many of which actually have
to do with the games microtransactions
one person's mad because they spent four
hundred and fifty dollars on the game
and then had their counts and because
they were using a third-party Pokemon
tracking app with niantic begun to crack
down on I'll give you a minute to think
about all the much better things that
you could get for 450 bucks other
complaints have been Judah private areas
serving as polka stops and gyms well
thing a lot of people to request access
to find credits so many details about
battlefield one single player campaign
dropped this week including who you'll
be playing as you'll be controlling for
characters a fighter pilot and armor
crewman a rebel fighter and a message
runner lead designer Danny Bolen is also
indicated that the campaign is going to
reflect battlefields open sandboxes more
closely so you may be saying goodbye to
those tight corridor combat spaces the
single-player campaign will include five
war stories called friends in high
places nothing is written through mud
and blood avanti savoia and the runner
avanti savoia will take you to the alps
in a battle between italy as the
austro-hungarian empire while the runner
will put you in the shoes of an anzac
messenger near the Gallipoli landing
site you can check out the full
description speech story on game [ __ ]
Assassin's Creed and Far Cry fans may
not want to hold your breath the next
installment as it may not be coming next
year Ubisoft video if gamma todd games
but what we saw in the development of
the next Assassin's Creed was that we
had an opportunity to take it to another
level so we said we'll take all the time
it takes to make the experience
fantastic it was feasible because we
have other games
huge potential in this game to
revolutionize the IP so we said let's
make sure we change our models so we
have more time and that we can bring
back a greater experience they explained
that it would be back when it's ready
ubisoft editorial vp tommy Francois
backed up TMO with slightly more
colorful language saying this is the
goal we're going for alpha one year
before more quality more polish so if
this means biting the bullet and not
having an assassin's game or a far cry
in 2017 he clarified that by alpha he
means getting things done but leaving
time for polish and innovation the next
Assassin's Creed title on the radar is
the FDA collection which is a
remastering of a c2 brotherhood and
revelation that's you out on November 15
the ps4 and Xbox one next up best buy
has revealed that they'll be selling a
version of the Skyrim remaster with a
dub Akuma okay Dovahkiin mask might be a
slightly too generous definition but $75
Dragonborn bundle does include a
physical copy of the game in a steelbook
case and a soft to looking Dragonborn
hat which should complete your shitty
Dovahkiin cosplay for Halloween the
special edition of the game will include
new visual effects including God raised
and new snow shaders and a bunch of
other graphical goodie finally no man's
sky is being investigated over
misleading advertising claims after
receiving multiple complaints the UK's
Advertising Standards Authority is
looking into worth of the game did
indeed publish misleading advertisements
according to Eurogamer the a-si can have
offending ads removed and blocked from
appearing again yes a confirm they've
reached out to hello games and valve in
an attempt to get answers about normal
guided versus onstage the current
concern appears to be over videos which
show animal and ship flying behavior
flowing water effects and large-scale
space combat
SI is also presenting questions over the
quality of the game's graphics as shown
on the steam page versus the game at
launch as well as its apparent
references to a lack of loading screen
how the trading systems would work and
factions lying over territory this week
on site and we check out a mind-boggling
Dishonored 2 mission chat about what the
division still has to offer and mess
with the custom character creator in WWE
2k 17 that is it for me this week and do
let me know what you cared about have
yourselves a lovely weekend and I will
see you again on Monday